هي مدينه اشباح منذ منذ ان جئنا الى هنا
منذ اسبوعين نسبه كبيره من السكان على
الاقل 80% غادروها كما تسمعين يعني
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه هناك
اشتباكات منذ صباح اليوم قصف شديد على هذه
المدينه وهناك تخوف كبير من ان يكون هناك
هجوم واسعه نطاق على هذه المدينه
الاستراتيجيه في الجبهه
الجنوبيه يعني على الاقل منذ ساعه تقريبا
احتدم القصف هناك قصف شديد هنا في وسط
المدينه تم استهداف ايضا مستشفى المدينه
منذ قليل لم تكن لم يكن هذا القصف يعني لم
يلحق اضرار كبيره بالمستشفى لكن هذا هو
واقع سكان هذه المدينه بقى فيها فقط
المئات ان كان وسط المدينه او حتى الجانب
الاخر من نهر ادنيبر هناك اقليه من السكان
بقت هنا تريد البقاء في المقابل
الالاف غادروا المدينه هربا من هذه الحرب
هذه الحرب التي تستد كل يوم في المنطقه
طيب يا محمد من خلال مكوثك في المنطقه
ولقائك مع الناس هل تلتمس امال
يعلق عليه من خلال العمليه العسكريه هؤلاء
السكان في عوده
السلام الى مناطقهم
على الاقل يعني ما تابعنا هنا ان من
ارادوا حتى البقاء يعني في اخر الايام
غادروها غادروا لانهم لماذا لان يقولوا
لنا انهم سئموا ذلك انهم يعني نفسيا هناك
ارهاق كبير خاصه في ظل هذا القصف المتواصل
وخاصه التخوف تخوف الكبير من عوده الروس
والدخول الى المدينه مجددا هناك لنقل ان
هذه المدينه هذه مدينه خرسون المدينه التي
تنزف في المقابل ضواحيها يعود تدريجيا
سكان هذه القرى والبلدات الصغيره يعودون
الى منازلهم رغم الدمار الكبيره الذي
لاحظناه هناك هناك بلدات يعني دمرت بشكل
كبير يحاولون العوده يحولون العوده الى
حياتهم الطبيعيه رغم رغم البنيه التحتيه
التي حطمت رغم المستشفيات التي ايضا
استهدفت وحتى انتشار الالغام وهي معضله
كبيره بالنسبه للسكان الضواحي خرسون لا
ننسى ان المدينه هي مدينه ايضا فلاحيه
بامتياز وبالتالي اليوم يجد المزارعون
انفسهم امام معضله هذه الالغام التي يجب
يتم انتشاله ليتمكنوا على الاقل من مباشره
عمله شكرا جزيلا لك مفدنا من خرسان محمد